so that uh that speaker vote in the
house was something else and uh we
watched I think McCarthy lose what was
it 15 times
14. 14 times the 15th was when he won so
anyway I'm losing my voice I didn't do
my uh normal morning segments and we're
just going to jump into it and talk
about what's going on with Congress
because Matt Gates is here and he's
already told us a whole bunch of
crazy-ish that we're like that can't be
true and he's like yeah I'm like okay so
let's just jump into the show smash the
like button subscribe to the channel
become a member at timcast.com we got
everybody here let's do a quick run of
introductions we're hanging out with
Matt Gates good to see you guys thanks
for having me I think everybody knows
who you are but brief introduction for
those who maybe don't I represent
Florida's first congressional district
been in Congress since my election in
2016. I'm on the armed services and
Judiciary committees hold on for now for
now hey guys my name is here of we are
change.org today I'm wearing a very
eloquent polite statement perfect for
dinner parties that says Joe and the
blank got to go uh a shirt that you
could get on thebestpolitical shorts.com
because you guys do that that's why I am
here thank you again so much for having
me I'm sorry really glad you're here man
hour away from DC we are there about
this should be happening frequently to
get the word of the people out from our
representatives to the people
so you keep using this Tech anyway let's
keep going Serge what's happening I'm
search.com what's up guys stoked that
you're here it's gonna be a good one all
right let's just jump into it so um Matt
you stood up to Kevin McCarthy to the
GOP establishment
several times as an understatement and
we we watched for for that you know week
or so and we were laughing the whole
time uh I am I am stoked that you're
here because I think what you did was
awesome but I'm curious to learn about
the details so
I heard about this Shadow document
apparently you and several others cut
some kind of deal or finally got
McCarthy to cave in and give you guys
something then we heard there's going to
be a floor vote to abolish the IRS just
just just tell us what's going on
because you know we're getting it all
second hand
look we believed that Washington was
broken the normal system of selecting
leadership in both parties is based on
the redistribution of lobbyists and
special interest money like if you want
to be the leader of your party you
basically have to raise and redistribute
north of 100 million dollars and Kevin
McCarthy was so good at that he raised
and distributed about half a billion
dollars over the course of the last
election cycle and so it creates a
covenant that's not really built on
trust or Merit or Vision but
trading money for political support
and we wanted to send a shock to that DC
cartel system and to say no guess what
there's going to have to be a different
way you get there and the concessions we
sought principally fell into like three
buckets
policy we wanted specific bills coming
to the floor we wanted commitments on
when they would come to the floor we
wanted uh adherence to specific spending
levels with a budget resolution and the
organizing principle of our policy goals
was really to make sure that we would
never again get an Omnibus Bill like we
had to vote on there's just a total joke
of a way of governing like how can we
sit here and honestly say that bills
that are thousands of pages of long that
spend 1.7 trillion dollars and that you
get 48 hours before having to cast a
vote is really legislating it's not it
devalues each individual member and it's
insulting to our constituents to suggest
that we even know what the hell we're
doing when that's the way we We Run The
Railroad
so we had policy concessions second was
procedure you know having those 72 hours
to read the bill having open amendments
like it's the youngest member of
Congress was not yet born the last time
the appropriate Appropriations process
went through regular order and that just
means like we should vote on the defense
stuff separately and then vote on like
the education stuff and then the Health
and Human Services stuff and that it
doesn't just all get mushed together so
somebody can vote for a bunch of
[ __ ] that you wouldn't otherwise
approve and then say well I had to vote
for it to fund our troops right that's
the game that's what the cartel builds
and lobbyists make a gazillion dollars
off of that the final leg of the stool
is Personnel like in order to enforce
the deal that we got we wanted specific
people on specific committees in
specific leadership posts and you know
what's the saying you rob the banks
because that's where the money's at well
we wanted
far more representation on the
Appropriations Committee because that's
where the money is and a lot of
Americans don't know what the rules
committee is or why that's important but
it totally governs
what we get to vote on and what we don't
get to vote on and so we demanded
specific people and specific
representation on the rules committee
I think we're going to be in a lot
stronger position as a result like the
critique I heard a few critiques during
this process one is like this was chaos
you showed the country you know how how
rough and tumble this is and you know
you should have done this behind closed
doors to hell with that man behind
closed doors is where the American
people have been getting screwed and so
I wanted to level my complaint on the
house floor specifically I wanted to
cite the people that I was objecting to
and their Ascension to leadership and uh
so I didn't buy that didn't mind and
then like it's like oh no this took this
you burned your whole first week there
are days in Congress where the only
thing we vote on is the renaming of one
post office
there are days in Congress where the
only thing we vote on are the rules that
govern the next vote
and we take six weeks off every year for
summer vacation where we do absolutely
nothing so to take four days to say this
is the policy this is the procedure this
is the Personnel that is going to drive
the Republican team going forward seems
like the best use of time since I've
been there so that was the the general
construct I mean that's that's amazing
why was it only 20 members of Congress
willing to stand up well I mean first of
all the the front line members even the
front line and when I say the front line
members I mean members that are in
districts that are 5149 maybe even
districts that Joe Biden won by a
substantial portion right
they had a loyalty to Kevin uh and an
argument that was something like this
well Matt if a guy goes out there and
spends you know four years taking money
from the lobbyists and giving them to
giving that money to us and then in the
last minute you knife that person no one
will ever agree to be the valet for
those people ever again and we need that
delivery system of resources and so like
it's not about how much we like or don't
like McCarthy it's about a system that
we rely on to Resource our campaigns and
I mean that's a pretty astonishing
argument but it it at least has a
logical construct and then you know
there are there are people who
fear disrupting the system they think
look I got here to Congress I've got a
staff that tells me I'm always losing
weight my jokes are funny like I go home
and I'm the the big cheese at The Rotary
Club and like to every extent that I can
have calm Waters the better and anything
that creates turbulence I oppose and
that's actually a pretty big swath of
the Republican conference and the
Democrat conference that that is how the
UNA party gets to group think yeah and
like I hear all this time these like
these geriatric Senators talking about
like all the importance of
these great bipartisan achievements but
so often in my life like the greatest
moments of unity have been the worst for
the people there's a [ __ ] ton of unity
to pass the Patriot Act yeah that's that
that thing we never thought it was
actually going to be used against
Patriots we thought it was going to be
used against you know Arabs and Far Away
lands you know there was a whole lot of
unity over the Iraq War everybody was
for that there was a ton of unity for
the coveted lockdowns there was a ton of
unity for just printing money and
sending it to people that weren't
working and so like whenever they're the
bills that are like the major bills that
have 90 95 support that's when you need
to be most worried at times
you fear retaliation
no because we built the tools in that
would that would allow us to have the
accountability I mean Nancy Pelosi is
going to go down in history as the last
of the Imperial speakers that
centralized power and that then you know
only doled out to members oh well you
can go rename a post office you can go
create a task force meanwhile the macro
economic decisions the major cultural
and policy decisions all get centralized
in the speaker's office where a lot of
the staff all went to like Northeastern
schools and are afraid of things like
fried food and guns and you know people
who enjoy those things right and uh Paul
Ryan gave an interview on CNN yesterday
that was really telling where he even
confessed like I had too much power as
Speaker like way too many of those
decisions were made without the people
who had spent years analyzing policies
uh seeing which programs had varying
levels of efficacy and so while you know
McCarthy I think to his credit at the
end of the day was willing to devolve a
lot of that power
we reinstituted the one member motion to
vacate the chair so for any reason at
any time any member can go to the floor
and call for a vote and to remove the
speaker of the house and if 218 people
vote for that motion then the speaker is
gone now I don't want to use that I
don't intend to use that but I think
having it on the books is healthy for
the institution so that there isn't fear
of retaliation for doing what's right
yeah it is the speaker works for us we
the people and it should be on a whim
taken out I mean I think that those
people are there to represent us if
they're not representing should be
removed instantly I love that idea
either thank you I mean they should at
least read the bills right if you're
going to pass a bill if you're going to
pass a law read to them for freak six
one one is man one of the things Ian's
brought up is that it should be illegal
to Pat to vote to vote on a bill that
you didn't read what do you think about
that well I mean then we wouldn't be
taking many votes I mean it's good you
know for yeah exactly I like that you
know that there was a moment during all
of this where people were like well okay
it's a few you and your 20 hold out stay
that way then we won't even be able to
organize and I'm think I'm thinking well
give us a lot of Leverage on the debt
limit you know if we if we didn't
constitute the house so yeah maybe
sometimes like you know a reflexive
legislative body isn't what's good for
the country yeah maybe less government
is good which which I think historically
that that point has proven many times
over and over again but I think it's
fair to say that there was also a lot of
contention between you and a lot of
other people I know Donald Trump was
also calling in specifically can you get
into some of the contention that was
happening there because it looked pretty
intense it looked pretty crazy and there
was also one specific photo of you
sitting there and there's a guy in your
face and it was a famous video
um and a famous picture that had the
caption this is how we know uh the Deep
State exists and you were kind of cool
and standing your ground there can you
tell us what was happening there behind
the scenes well first of all I don't get
rattled when people yell at me in public
because it happens like three times a
week so for a lot of members of Congress
like having your colleagues like upset
at you or yelling at you like that's
deeply uncomfortable and really that did
not affect my my week at all because
what I knew is that our argument about
how corrupt and how flawed the
decision-making is in Washington was
getting out and that it was and it was
breaking through
I think the contention was overplayed
because of the cameras look a lot of
times like the the late Don young almost
like pulled a knife on Me on the floor
because I wouldn't vote for a bill that
he had regarding like sea lions or
something like that you know and so
there there are always contentious
moments but usually if you just have
that one C-SPAN camera angle and not the
dynamic angles to see how people are
interacting you don't capture a lot of
it so look you know anybody we got 435
people you got a variety of different
alliances and opinions and grievances
that change over time I think that one
of the interesting Arguments for term
limits and I'm very glad we're getting
an actual vote on term limits because
everybody talks about it in their
campaigns but when every vote on it is
that like the churn ensures that
long-standing Boomer grudges don't
become a governing principle he's like
now if you know somebody who's the lead
person on financial services or on the
Ways and Means Committee just hates you
like you're not going to get your idea
through and they they can just Outlast
you whereas in a term limits environment
those grudges dissolve every time the
Congress turns over the legislative body
turns over you mentioned the debt
ceiling a little bit ago you guys are
about to vote on a debt ceiling in the
next four months so I my whole life I've
been watching them incrementally raise
the debt ceiling over and over and over
and the thing is it's from my point of
view it's supposed to be a ceiling that
you don't print more money than that
because that's the ceiling so can we
like make a realistic debt ceiling of
like 1.4 quadrillion just say we're
gonna get there eventually we we can
survive this amount we're going to print
another 7 000 trillion dollars
um because I think we are going to I
don't know do you think maybe we won't
um what do you think about that idea is
that just too far out what are you in
well you're you're right that it's it's
a joke because there is no real plan to
ensure that we have a cap on that which
we will borrow and spend and I think the
reason this continues to get worse on
the books is because like regular
Americans don't feel the pain of the
national debt in approximate way like if
an illegal immigrant you know runs over
your family member you feel that right
if you know you of someone in your
household loses their job there's a
direct impact you see if the factory
that your mom worked at goes to you know
Chihuahua Mexico that is a traceable
thing but so long as we're the global
Reserve currency we're able to sort of
um
exist in this era of expanding debt now
we're starting to pay the price with
Rising inflation but you know the there
is no real Lobby or special interest for
Less spending in Washington like that's
the problem go on K Street throw a rock
and you're going to hit someone who's
paid a lot of money to get more spending
in one way or the other and so like the
way we compromise is just by doing all
of it whether it's defense non-defense
discretionary non-discretionary
mandatory and that is how like the
uniparty works so the
demand we put with the leverage we had
in the speakers race was that the House
of Representatives must pass a budget
resolution at the 2022 spending levels
so roll this thing back a couple years
and it's similar to like in 2015 when
they did cut cap and balance and so here
all of what we do has to go under those
spending levels and look it's going to
mean Some Cuts in areas that I support
like defense but if we've got to cut to
fence maybe we ought to cut all the
money we spend defending other nations
far away like Ukraine hey Pakistan needs
their gender studies okay I think it's
imperative for the world where would we
finance that as well as you know beagle
torture by Dr fauci we need to finance
that who else is going to do it unless
we do it so I'm just I'm just being
facetious here but obviously there's a
lot of Wheeling and dealing in
Washington DC and we saw that through of
course this larger uh vote for the
Speaker of the House you saw a lot of it
we saw a lot of people like MTG also a
lot of individuals like Thomas Macy not
really kind of join your cause there are
you able to speak about some of the
deals that were being made there and
what was being negotiated behind the
scenes because we know publicly there
was a lot said but there's also a lot of
closed door meetings that we didn't get
to see are you able to to talk about
that sure I mean Thomas Massey wall he
voted for McCarthy on every ballot he
was there with us in the back rooms
helping write a lot of the fiscal policy
that ended up undergirding the agreement
and MTG you know she is an inspirational
Force I consider her
probably my closest Ally in all of
Congress and she uh deserves to be on
committees and what the Democrats did to
her was so wrong and so egregious and I
think that she had an earlier
understanding with speaker McCarthy that
she would get back on committees that
they would be meaningful committees that
they would tailor to her skill set and I
think that was sufficient for her to
support him we sought some broader
structural changes we achieved those the
changes and concessions we got out of
McCarthy are only going to endure to the
benefit of MTG because she's one of our
more Dynamic and fearless members I like
uh Kevin's Behavior the last week
McCarthy oh yeah how would you rate his
yeah look him being speaker of the house
this week well one of the things that
was not in the rules but was part of our
addendum agreement was that the 14 000
hours had to be released of the footage
from January 6th and the speaker has
custodial oversight of a lot of those
records and he made that commitment and
then today he reaffirmed it publicly
that that's exactly what we're going to
do so yeah that you know trust is a
series of Promises Kept and I believe
that McCarthy deserves the opportunity
to keep the promises he made and so far
he's on the right track is he going to
have a grudge against you
I don't know that I'm going to be on his
Christmas card list but you know it
doesn't like that that's not really what
it's about you know he knows very
clearly what my objectives are and what
it took to get us to go forward with a
speaker and he is performing to that
expectation it's you know it's not
personal for me it's business I'd love
to get you guys in together to debate
live on the show that'd be hot well I
mean what what would the the best
outcome of that have been Jim Jordan or
or Byron Donald's look I I think that
Jim Jordan is our most talented member
I think he's our hardest working member
he is one of my mentors he inspires me
but you know it got to a point where
there were six holdouts where you don't
we didn't want to drive McCarthy into
the arms of the Democrats right so once
the margin gets that low McCarthy could
in theory have gone to the Democrats
gotten you know four five six of them to
get instant covid in exchange for
draining our subpoena Authority and then
he would have ascended to the
speakership anyway all of the features
of our deal would have dissolved and
then every time we didn't send a
subpoena to hold government accountable
he could have said well that's Matt
Gates's fault so we didn't want to put
him in that position the country in that
position the house in that position and
so that's why we crafted what we thought
was the a deal that was not reliant on
trust but that had clear enforcement
triggers Eric's walwell Adam Schiff
they're getting removed from their
committees right yeah do you think
that's a good thing
yeah I think that the Democrats kind of
you know crossed the Rubicon on this
when they threw MTG and gosar off
committees without a basis and there is
sufficient basis with Schiff in
particular I agree and uh you know
swallow well now
I don't think the like the grave swallow
well emergency is the Fang Fang thing I
think it's more the role he played in
the Russia hoax like when you go out
there and say there's evidence that the
president United States is a Russian
agent and then you don't deliver on that
you shouldn't get to serve on the major
committees that have access to the most
sensitive Intelligence on the planet
Earth
I agree and Adam but like the Fang Fang
thing yeah poor thing yeah listen listen
the the internet is not gonna like what
I have to say maybe but within the
Republican conference I am swalwell's
biggest defender on the Fang Fang thing
and here is why he was a city councilman
in the city of Dublin and some chick
showed up with money wanting to hook up
with him you think that like he's a
single guy like running around southern
or running around California and he's
supposed to have like the defensive
briefing to turn down some like hot
Chinese chick chick that was wanting to
like donate money and jump in bed with
him he wasn't a member of Congress he
didn't have access to intelligence the
what most sensitive information he was
working on was like the sewage system of
the city of Dublin so I think you
probably give the guy a break for that
well you don't give him a break for is
then come in here and weaving these
whole lies onto half truths to try to
destabilize the presidency in the
country that's far more egregious than
the Fang Fang thing was he with Fang
thing while he was in Congress no that
was when he was on the city council
somewhere in nowhere California oh but
there's also with Adam Chef the release
of phone records of private citizens and
Nunes yeah oh yeah well Schiff is truly
the worst member of Congress he is he I
mean he is uh it's like looking into the
eyes of evil with that guy he's always
gonna say I think he's an evil man yeah
he has no reflection
what is going on and if you bring garlic
around his like skin starts to burn I
haven't talked to him but I think he's
got that same mindset that he's like
these people are evil and then other
people like he's evil like what is going
on dude a breakdown of communication he
held up an envelope on TV saying that it
was proof Trump colluded with Russia or
whatever and that he couldn't show
anybody like that's what happened it's
been a while yeah well and then he like
made up
a a construct of a transcript between
zelinski and Trump that just didn't
happen it was just willed into existence
by his imagination and I mean he's done
such damage to our intelligence
community and like there is a place for
the United States to like know what's
going on in the world usually knowledge
is power right but the way he weaponized
it and really started with a lot of the
Obama people like do you say what you
will about Obama the guy was good at
vertically integrating Personnel in a
lot of these agencies where where the
bureaucracy would bend to their will
like if there's a fair critique of trump
it's that you know he was this great
Visionary but oftentimes the people that
were two three four layers down were
working against him and he didn't roll
into the presidency with this terrific
Rolodex of people that could go and
operate at that level whereas you know
Schiff Obama like these these people
were good at getting people in place to
drive action and we should learn from
that is it because they were hooked up
with the liberal economic order at the
time and like they just had all the
backing of right there's a whole
emphasis like if you're part of the
prevailing way of thinking the National
Security State the neoconservative
worldview there's an entire
infrastructure there to like build out
your career there are endowed
professional professorships there are
think tanks that are ready to give you
six figure jobs there's a like career
progression of jobs on the hill but if
you think differently you're kind of
hunted in a lot you know you're hunted
canceled they do everything to
compromise you and if that doesn't work
they try to destroy you what do you
there's a lot of compromise um
especially in Washington DC but but how
deep does the rabbit hole goal be go
because there's a lot of people talking
about you know the Deep State the
intelligence agencies having a lot of
control using a lot of extortion special
interests interest groups pulling the
strings here what's your understanding
of how things really work in Washington
DC compared to what the average American
kind of sees well I think like the most
corrupt
like
foray into this is like freshman
orientation because like you show up
here and I mean you know imagine showing
up from Northwest Arkansas from like you
know Southern Mississippi and you see
the architecture of DC they take you out
to like the finest steakhouse the best
wine you've ever had and co-located at
your table are the lobbyists for the
major special interests for the
Committees that you're interested that
you want to serve on so like I get here
and they're like oh Gates you want to be
on the armed services committee have you
met these defense contractors these are
the key lobbyists that round up the
defense money and they put you with them
from the very beginning and you sort of
get the joke that if you give your vote
card to the leadership and your calendar
to the lobby Corps you just kind of get
enveloped into a system that's there to
nurture you and protect you and keep you
out of Harm's Way and all it costs you
is your own belief set and I don't think
that's compromised so much as selling
out now you know that so that is like
step one and that catches a whole lot of
the people who to get here and then
beyond that if you kind of resist that
system then they do try to extort you
engage in anything they can do to
compromise you cancel you find some joke
that you liked on Instagram years ago
that like doesn't fit with the mores of
this time find some email that you are
on like the forward chain of it's like
some basis to say that you're a white
supremacist or you're you know some sort
of unacceptable human that can't be in
polite company and uh you know then if
that doesn't work it's abject
destruction through the political
process where there are
many many dollars lined up solely for
the extermination of those who push back
against against the narrative yeah this
is detailed extensively in books like
the the economic Hitman that I think are
definitely worth reading and checking
out here but talking to previous members
of Congress it's really kind of daunting
to see what they have to go through how
much pressure they have to go through
how much agreement they have to agree to
before even getting into some of those
positions of power
um from the dues it's money I mean it's
there's specific dollar amounts I mean I
remember you know going in and saying
well I want to be on the armed services
committee and someone looked me dead in
the eye and said well that'll be seventy
five thousand dollars that you owe to
the leadership funds and and to the
Republican Congressional committee and
so you know I I go home and think well
you know part of you wants to say screw
you or like are you wearing a wire yeah
if I could ask if I could ask you and
again you don't have to answer this but
who do you think is more influential and
Powerful in Washington DC the lobbyists
or the intelligence agencies well I mean
the answer to the question is yes
they're one and the same because because
often oftentimes they are fused with
precisely the same Personnel where
people will roll out of doj and end up
at you know the law firm that Services
the lobby Corps and and the very same
clients I mean there's no better example
of the fusion of that than when I
learned through a whistleblower that the
the Perkins cui Law Firm which is the
legal wing of the democratic party has
within it a secure information facility
that is run by the FBI
so they literally have a place in their
Law Firm where they can try to convert
political dirt into intelligence
investigations counterintelligence
investigations criminal investigations
and the like yeah and let's not forget
all the epsteins it's up and running
today and they have all the Epstein
tapes too but that's another thing do
you have any hope in the Jim Jordan uh
new committee when it comes to
investigating the weaponization of
government do you think that's going to
be akin to maybe a church committee yeah
that that's our objective and the
specific agreement we have with McCarthy
is that that select committee will have
the budget Resources Personnel no less
than the Democrats January 6 committee
well what do you think do you think
it'll work out uh look it's hard to
promise outcomes when we don't have the
ability to throw handcuffs on anybody or
put anybody in jail right all we can do
is expose facts and so it relies on
other features of our system to kind of
go end to end on that accountability and
so I don't want to promise people like
yeah you know you're going to see Hunter
Biden hauled off in cuffs you're going
to see the Joe Biden University of Penn
like China money laundering stuff and
you know because
that may be out there but it may not
result in precisely what people would
hope upon upon encountering the
information and you want to ask about
you made that point about sometimes no
investigation is better than
investigation oh yeah especially like
with the nist investigation for 9 11 I
mean there's so many holes in that thing
if you look at it objectively like I'm
concerned that
they would put forth an investigation
but it ends up being a sham and then
they're like okay we did it our
investigation's over everyone we didn't
find anything don't ask again as opposed
to no investigation and then this is the
Saudis Playbook right I mean you know
the Saudis were able to avoid the
responsibility uh that they have in the
911 attacks and in a terrorist attack in
my District in Pensacola
because they get a nice little report
written that you know sufficient to
absolve them and then they say oh well
not look not nothing to see here you
don't need to come back and conduct any
further inquiry do you fear or is that
concern when when creating Committees of
I don't know because I'm like well we
need an independent committee but who's
deciding who's on the independent
committee like how do you ensure that it
isn't a sham
Personnel I mean that that's why we know
that the people who will be on that
committee will be people like Jim Jordan
chip Roy Thomas Massey people actually
ask tough questions what is the point
what is the goal exactly like Are there
specific um directions that you guys are
aiming at thus far have you decided like
what what I don't know departments are
going to be investigated or what is our
specific things being looked for
yeah you heard McCarthy in his uh Speech
single out the FBI right he did not talk
about like a weaponized government in
the abstract when he spoke he spoke
specifically about politics at the FBI
so one of our first areas of inquiry is
going to be this Timothy t-ball guy who
suppressed information that was
derogatory to the bidens and did not
allow the normal process of criminal
inquiry to continue there and and they
do everything they can at the FBI to try
to supercharge anything that is related
to Trump or anyone around Trump or
anybody who's on the right and then if
it's the bidens they they function as
their Defender and they suppress the
derogatory information so that's
probably where we start I wonder how it
is that you know Trump being a wealthy
Elite and all that stuff still ends up
outside the big club that you know Joe
Biden seems to get away with everything
but Donald Trump is the target of
everything
do you think that it's it's a function
of elitism or do you think it's a
function of like Joe Biden just being of
the system right I mean he's all he is
of this place uh he chaired you know
foreign affairs in the Senate where you
interact with a lot of the people who
end up in powerful positions in the
intelligence community
and Trump went in with a goal of
reorganizing that and changing it and
that's I think why they kick back at him
so hard what I don't understand though
is if Trump or let's say Joe Biden is
part of the liberal economic order
that's you know we're evolving to a new
world order they say George Bush Senior
said that Klaus Schwab's intimated that
lots of people around the world aren't
realizing we're globalizing a new world
order it's not about American military
bases everywhere anymore now we're gonna
have a new type of thing but in that
instance I would think that the
Americans would want the Russians on
their side not siding with China and the
Chinese economic order I don't
understand why why are people pushing
Russia away if they're trying to create
a new world it's going to make them I'm
concerned it would make America number
three
well I mean what we're seeing right now
is the leverage buyout of Russia from
with a lot of Chinese cash I mean
they're they're more Chinese with two
million dollars cash in their bank
account right now like uh U.S uh
equivalent then there are total
Canadians
and so you know yeah you're you're
seeing uh a lot of the Farmland you know
in Russia uh get just bought out by the
Chinese and it it fuses those systems in
a way that poses a real substantial
threat to the United States to the West
at large aren't they buying our Farmland
as well yeah
I thought that maybe colonized maybe we
could propose some sort of peace deal
between Russia and Ukraine because the
what they're doing it looks like Putin's
trying to take a land bridge to Crimea
so that he has warm water access into
the Black Sea Russia basically after the
Soviet Union split up they they took it
all away from Russia and they gave
um they gave it to to Ukraine the city
what's the big city there right on the
right on the in Crimea and I think what
what we need to do is establish I don't
think Russia is ever going to stop until
they get a land bridge into Crimea in a
warm water Seaport so has that come up
in Congress you guys are like can we
I've got a pretty cynical view on the
you know Russia Ukraine conflict I uh
I've been voting against sending more
weapons there hold on let me get this
cough drop in yeah dog I'll give you
guys well the geopolitical situation uh
especially yeah that's happening right
now and you're getting yeah a lot of
people in the comment section are saying
this is cough cast it's coffee uh
unfolding right now I think I'm the only
one lost my voice meaning are the only
ones holding on here but it is a very
complex GOP political situation that I
think represents the larger proxy war
between the East and the West I think
sending in more weapons prolongs this
proxy conflict makes sure that of course
it goes on forever I think this war is
meant to be continued and not one
there's also a lot of debates now about
tanks uh to me do you think there's a
possibility for any kind of peace deal
because I think it's getting
um co-opted so many times including by
individuals like Boris Johnson that
literally go to Ukraine and say no
you're not going to even sit at the
table here with the Russians do you
think one year from now 10 years from
now there's some kind of possibility for
peace here or is this just going to be
who makes money on a previous deal
that's true yep right
I mean peace is not nearly as profitable
to those who
are in the war business you know it's
it's uh so obviously I don't have to say
it out loud I mean to me our involvement
in Ukraine is directly linked to our
diminished involvement in Afghanistan
like Afghanistan was the money
laundering capital of the world for like
a lot of our lifetime a lot of that cash
was like run through Dubai and you know
Abu Dhabi
and when that was not the corrupt
country that we just decided to pour
American Cash on like we needed another
historically corrupt country to go poor
American Military material and cash into
and gain of function research too
Ukraine fit the bill and so I don't
believe that like anyone's really
working toward peace I think that
they're very powerful interests that
benefit if this is a long-term low-yield
War yes CNN is even reporting right now
that the United States is running low on
some weapons and ammunition because
they're transferring so much of it to
Ukraine right now so that's that's
staggering and also a dangerous for the
United States to be in such a vulnerable
spot as well so I I think you're
absolutely right there's a lot of bigger
interest here BlackRock just signed a
deal with Ukraine that they're going to
be rebuilding Ukraine as of course
BlackRock also has a lot of deals
funding uh and being a part of the
military-industrial complex that you see
the circle of life they're kind of
involving there is there any way to kind
of address this is there anything that
we could do as people to bring awareness
to this is there any way there could be
some kind of Peace here well the trend
lines are coming in my direction when it
comes to public perception on this I
mean initially like the American people
were dying to send every American dollar
you know to Ukraine and increasingly at
least within the Republican Party you've
started to see that shift as our
economic conditions are more in the
Forefront of people's minds like we have
laws that require end-to-end monitoring
of materiel when we send it into a war
zone and
I am not convinced We are following is
it because we're not technically at War
the United States hasn't been
technically at a war since World War II
well in a we do have regs that Define a
conflict Zone and whenever we send stuff
that kills into one of those places
we're supposed to know who has it and we
don't and that is concerning to me if
that's like the new thing is like oh
well you know send the stuff anything
what was it that Ben sass said when he
was in the Senate if it shoots send it
and so we've been doing all of that and
I think that in some ways prolongs
conflict it doesn't bring us to a faster
resolution to continue to pour cash and
weapons into a historically corrupt
country that is fighting yeah Dave Smith
would say and has said if you want to
see who our next big enemy is going to
be look at who we're funding right now
and I'm concerned that the the knots I
don't know if they're technically are
they considered Nazis let's be uh what
is it the Democrats thought so I mean
you had you had uh dozens of Democrats
signing letters saying that the azov
Battalion were a bunch of white
supremacists and while they want to call
our own military who are patriots a
bunch of white supremacists here they
got no problem draining the resources of
our country to go and fund who they were
just calling white supremacists you know
like a couple years ago so if in six
years the azov start Exterminating a
race because they are happen to be
genocidal or racist like then what is
the American you're going to use that as
evidence to go to war in Ukraine to
fight the azov and now we've got a more
military bases in Ukraine protecting the
Suez Canal yep well there's a lot of
Intel reports of a lot of uh Advanced
U.S military hardware being sold on the
black markets as well and a lot of the
weapons even according to CBS News and
Aid not making it to its official
destination and I think that's that's
such a travesty because there's so much
human suffering in that country there's
so many people use this ponds there's so
many people hurt with this larger
conflict there's such a bigger
immigration crisis here how do you see
all of this going because you have a lot
of you know uh you're in Congress you
talk to a lot of people there how do you
see this kind of unfolding here with
this never-ending War where where are we
going to be a couple years from now with
this continuing the way it is what
worries me is like you cannot overstate
the gravity of some of the worst
potential outcome sets here I mean you
know Russia much like a bond villain
sort of becomes more and more dangerous
during its demise it's it's a
kleptocracy in a lot of ways I mean a
lot of people have gotten out of Russia
with whatever they could steal on their
way out right to your point about the
material in the black market and so I
think that for us to go and like play a
game of nuclear chicken over which guy
in a track suit gets to run Crimea is
foolish and it's not it's not how
serious a serious country ought to
behave you think World War III could
result from recklessness of course of
course this is a Tinder Box and it's not
Syria right it's Russia and Ukraine it
is a country that has enough nuclear
power to end Earth multiple times over
and it's a leader who I don't think is
making stable rational decisions in
Vladimir Putin and you know to continue
to send the high Mars there to send the
Bradleys there from the United States
seem is provocative to me now why isn't
this Europe's problem right you would
think that Germany and the other powers
in Europe would have the most at stake
but what they do you know as these
European Democracies face elections and
as their reserves go down like you're
gonna see them
have a different posture towards Russia
as their mandates expire and as they
have to go back for elections plus they
rely on us for defense right well I mean
we're that was TR one of the principal
critiques that Trump made that I think
got a lot of disaffected people to
support him is when he said we're I'm
just tired of being like dead money at
the world stage like being the world's
policeman being the world's piggy bank
has not been good for the American
middle class yeah Trump also made sure
that he sent lethal weapons to Ukraine
something Obama was even afraid to do so
I mean this conflict has been brewing
for so long since 2014 even before that
with their Kind of Revolution that's
happening there but it's it to me this
is just such such a sad thing to see
Humanity go through
um but
um
I I don't know I I just I just hope this
kind of end somehow I don't think it is
I don't know if we should potentially
even change what do you think when you
see your leaders in Congress where the
like American flag Ukraine flag like pin
around wasn't McCarthy doing that yep
I saw a photo I don't know if it was
real it seems like they don't understand
that Russia needs a warm water or wants
a warm water port in the Black Sea like
if that if that was understood and it's
like yo this is about trade this is
about Russia yeah you think it's just a
real estate play yeah do you think he
takes that energy gas problem natural
gas Etc it's real estate yeah I think it
is 100 real estate and I don't know why
there's not more American English media
Putin talking real estate but energy
right so yeah Transportation Control is
a large portion of the natural gas from
Russia into into Europe Western power to
the Suez Canal which is all of the
Indian Ocean and things like that put
some weights on Russia Russia doesn't
like it Russia says we're going to go
and take the port back
War so that's what I think is that
they're missing it that they just don't
that they're emotionally uh blockade
their their perception is being
blockaded by emotions because it's
always horrible to see someone get
killed or to see a house get blown up or
Invasion or anything that's horrible you
know I'm against War you know I mean I I
think that it's one of the reasons why
I'm a little more dovish in My Views I I
think oftentimes both sides lose
yeah I wonder if like you know the world
economic Forum Davos group types have um
substantial influence when it comes to
the wars we declare
have you been uh yeah why is that an
open question in your mind no I think
they do life course what I mean is to
what degree right
because obviously the goals they have
the actions we take align with them so
it's it's like the US has no reason to
be involved in Ukraine like you said
Europe's problem yet for some reason
we're acting like one body yeah we're
the we're the military arm of the
liberal economic order the British
Empire basically have you been asked
that turned out well yeah have you been
asked to be a part of the world economic
forum and what kind of influence do you
think they kind of have on uh the United
States since Klaus Schwab openly brags
about how he has half of the Canadian
Parliament being young members of the
world economic Forum yeah no I I think
that that it's part of the like
political industrial complex it's the
finance wing of the political industrial
complex and so like if what you need to
keep your power and to win your
elections is a Super PAC that shows up
with you know 10 million dollars in dark
money like who do you think Cuts those
checks
you think it's like some guy who's like
a Furniture tycoon in Oklahoma it's not
bang for international settlement and
everybody knows it and everybody knows
and like you know this is an area where
the populist right and the populace left
need to work together on the way that we
fund campaigns in this country because
it like it always works to the benefit
of the uni party and I don't get why
people should be able to put unlimited
money without disclosure into
manipulating the viewpoints of Americans
do you think politically there's going
to be some kind of Rift and change here
because there does seem to be obviously
the the Democrats and the Republicans
but there also seems to be a bigger Rift
amongst the establishment and the
anti-establishment totally uh there's a
lot of populists there's also a lot of
statists there's a lot of rhinos there's
a lot of neocons it's like a civil war
within the Civil War within the Civil
War politically speaking not violently
speaking
um do you see the political landscape
changing in the future because I I think
a lot of people are sick of these
neocons of these kind of rhinos and they
don't really represent the American
people we had enough of George W bush he
had his time he ruined that time and I
think he spurred uh uh you know a
situation where now the Democrats have a
lot of power you know when I first got
elected to congress we could have a lot
of collaboration between the populist
right and the populace left on things
like War Powers the surveillance State
um political reforms that don't just
Empower kind of the PAC structure
and then January 6 happened and like
those populist leftists like would not
talk to us I mean would not collaborate
with us on bills would not engage in any
way and it became so it became such a
point of personal trauma for some of
them and I don't think that was good for
the country I don't think that was good
for kind of the anti-establishment unity
that we need I will say that like since
Republicans took the majority they've uh
they've been a lot nicer to us dude but
we saw you uh talking with AOC during
this whole process right was that was
that something relevant or that you can
share sure I mean and I I got caught on
camera in conversations with AOC ilhan
Omar and pramila jayapal like three
people who
folks have seen me disagree with more
than agree with with AOC I was
discussing whether or not the Democrats
were going to leave the floor and cut a
deal with McCarthy because that would
have changed the math on the speaker
vote
and so she was actually doing everything
possible to make sure that they didn't
and that there were 212 Democrats voting
for Jeffries on every ballot wow with
jayapal we've worked together on
legislation to break up big Tech and I
was talking to her about the prospects
in a republican Congress and a
republican House of getting some
bipartisan bicameral solutions to
reshape a lot of these companies and the
jayapal legislation from the 117th
Congress like was not you know taking
immunities away and all that it said no
like
meta has to alienate their Instagram
asset Google has to alienate email from
search and like literally breaking up
these companies and then with Omar we
were actually talking about War Powers
and wow I was I was teasing her a bit
like I was like you guys like showed up
here and said the military was racist
and like before before you were done
being in the majority you were like
voting for NATO okay you know what what
went what went on there and so I was a I
was a teasing her well what did go on
there hypocrisy
you know tribalism I think that they
um they got drafted into that
establishment Democrat thinking yeah I
don't think that the squad really
believes that like NATO is advancing the
interests of their constituents on a day
in day out basis but yet they were still
willing to vote for all these like NATO
strengthening Endeavors well there's oh
God are there some issues that could
Bridge the the kind of populists left
and the populist rights together are
there some things that we could actually
agree upon that could bring this country
back together the first thing that comes
to mind personally is the Epstein
Scandal I think everyone on the left and
right agrees in that but are there some
issues that you think could uh could you
guys could work how about abolishing
fisa right I mean why wouldn't the
populist writing populist left agree to
take down some elements of the
surveillance state
yeah absolutely another idea would be
cleaning up the environment like the
atmosphere pulling carbon out of the
atmosphere you can convert it into
graphene or you know here we go everyone
drink correctly no I'm all about the
carbon capture stuff and also this is a
part of like the libertarian thing that
I don't get like why would we
As Americans give carte blanche to a
bunch of powerful businesses to pollute
our air and our water uh to me America
First means that you actually have to
want this to be a beautiful place and
and so I do think that like making sure
that we don't completely sell out to
people to to trash our nation it would
would be important regarding using um
the government to protect us from
corporations you were talking about
breaking up big Tech earlier I think a
mistake that we should not make is what
they did to Rockefeller with his
Standard Oil they broke it up into like
seven or eight oil companies and then he
made more money off of these new so like
breaking up Facebook into Facebook Prime
Facebook Messenger Instagram is
different companies mark would still
have the code he'd still be able to run
software like that so I'm thinking we
need to make them free their software
code so that other people can spin up
versions of those websites interlock
them my version of Facebook can
interoperate with your with Mark
Zuckerberg's version
I think the interoperability of data is
really what you're what you're talking
about Force the companies and it's sort
of like um sort of like breaking
Monopoly but we're not actually breaking
the company apart but where I disagree
is giving your proprietary code up is
basically it's your your ownership your
intellectual property but releasing the
algorithmic code yeah how they
manipulate the public with algorithms I
think is extremely important I think
that's the path for big Set uh big Tech
to heal the system with big Tech as
opposed to trying to smash up companies
and make them do what the government
says they have to do like let them ban
whoever they want but if they're not if
they have bad terms of service and your
version of the site has better terms of
service they're going to lose you well
yeah go ahead no I got I got a different
question so no I don't know about you
but I think uh big Tech had a huge
influence in this latest midterm
election I think they're also
essentially controlling what a lot of
people see and think with their
algorithms they're becoming a huge
powerful entity that of course also now
we're finding out through the Twitter
files work for the private intelligence
agencies that curation that ability to
to control what people see and listen to
that's a huge power I personally think
it had an effect on the election and I
think it's going to continue to have
bigger effects on the election
especially in places that took a lot of
the Zucker bucks Florida was one of the
states that refused money from Facebook
and Mark Zuckerberg and their elections
went totally different than a lot of
states that did is there a solution to
this is there a way to kind of rein in
these intelligence agencies that are
controlling big Tech that are
essentially asserting their will on
everyone else
I think that on the election front the
specific algorithmic work to Target
certain types of Voters to push
registration to push vote by mail to
push early voting to do election day
awareness like that is that is partisan
based on who they are trying to Target
those messages to right and that should
be transparent and if it was transparent
I actually think the right enforcement
tool is the federal elections Commission
because you know when a when Facebook
says okay well like we're going to
Target this exact population of people
with this age range and this ZIP code
that is a donation to a political party
and a political movement and should be
subject to the same caps that any other
American would be subject to I got a
question for the audience
DeSantis Gates 2024 I'm for Trump yeah
I'm for Trump I I think the world of
DeSantis I Trump Gates 2024. well uh I
would do anything the president asked
but I think he's got better choices I
like what I'm what I'm doing now you
know I was very involved into Santa's
first campaign I was his transition
chairman when he came into the
governorship in Florida I helped him
hire a lot of the folks that shape the
policy that make Florida the Envy of the
country right now uh I think Ron
DeSantis will be president one day but
in 2024 it's uh My Hope and expectation
will be Donald Trump what do you think
about Donald Trump still telling
everyone to get vaccinated that's been
one of the core issues that kind of been
a a big kind of uh shock to a lot of
people especially a lot of dude the
Boomers love the facts I mean I mean
right now with the FDA what was the
Saturday Night Live thing where there
was like the Boomers left the bat
if they're still around but uh the FDA
and CDC just came out and said that
they're going to be investigating
possible very serious side effects
that's is an issue that is concerning to
a lot of people especially a lot of
trump supporters let's let's pull this
up actually we have this from Politico
CDC fdac possible link between pfizers
by valence shot and strokes The Agency
said the surveillance signal is very
unlikely to represent a true clinical
risk and said they will continue to
recommend the vaccine so this obviously
has a lot of people worried you knew
what the tell was it was when the number
one thing Republicans were lobbying for
was were immunity protections and
liability protections for the vaccine
manufacturers I mean you knew at the
very beginning this was going to be an
issue because they had to they had to
lay out all of their immunities and
protection and because YouTube was
censoring anybody who brought that up
how are you still on YouTube like you
know by thread I'm telling you we argue
with each other like if I say anything
about covid for the most part Tim will
be like no no no and then we'll let go
at it and we never make definitive
claims very very rarely make definitive
claims about things we don't have proof
it's it's basically just like look we're
reading Politico here you know what I
mean hey man if YouTube's got a problem
with Politico the BBC CNN all reports
supporting this well then we're all
asked marjor Taylor green got got zapped
off of social media for saying that if
you were really overweight that was
probably a bad idea vis-a-vis covid and
exercise would be helpful and then you
you know lo and behold you later see CNN
and the CDC Credit accept those
positions Crowder uh Stephen Crowder got
a strike for citing the CDC yeah it's
but but today's pretty big especially
with this FDA CDC news that uh almost
everyone in the corporate media is
talking about the British Broadcasting
Company even had a cardiologist on that
they're getting criticized for having on
a doctor a Mainline professional that
was talking about the larger concerns
when it came to this of course shot and
larger health effects that are being
correlated here I know Florida is
investigating that right now under Ron
DeSantis but I see this yeah but I see
this as being a very key divisive issue
especially when it comes to the
Republican primaries especially when it
comes to the possibility of DeSantis and
Trump kind of heading uh going at each
other how do you see that larger battle
unfold and do you think there's going to
be any accountability against big Pharma
for a lot of their kind of egregious
actions and a lot of their data that
they're hiding from the American people
no I mean there are multiple big Pharma
lobbyists for every single member of
Congress you want to talk about a
special interest that has a death grip
on the political process it is Big
Pharma and I don't know that the vax
Mandate in the 2024 primaries will still
be like at the top of the issue Matrix I
I think this economy is about to go
through a serious contraction I think
that people are going to see their 401ks
experience real problems I think that as
interest rates rise and we that has such
an impact on our nation's debt service
and and how far the dollar can go
purchasing power business confidence
consumer confidence I think like that's
going to be the issue Matrix along with
the Border in 2024 and a lot of places
are getting rid of the vaccinated I mean
I'm grateful that the Department of
Defense is ditching the vax Mandate the
fight over we've got to reinstate people
who saw their lives ruined but I don't
see it being a big deal you do need a
vaccine to enter the United States if
you're not a citizen you need one to go
to so tomorrow I'm on CNN I'm on uh
smirkconisha's show so I was going to
come into the studio do the stick there
and they're like produce your vaccine
your booster where you triple boosted
did you get a booster this morning do
you have a negative test and I'm like
I'm not doing any of that stuff so I've
got to shoot the the segment remote but
then every time I see like my Republican
colleagues now on set in the studio I'm
like you know we we had on the
krakensteins the other day they're
Democrats and I asked them if they
thought the economy was good fairly good
bad and they said somewhere between
fairly bad and fairly good and if you
look at the polling the majority the
plurality of people and the majority
think it's fairly bad or Worse 40 say
very bad so we got the story about Joe
Biden and the documents in his garage
meanwhile it's like nine dollars in some
places for a carton of eggs you know
milk is really expensive I think the
average person when it comes to the
issue Matrix like you're mentioning is
just sitting there wondering why cabbage
costs seven dollars yeah I mean I looked
at the little head of cauliflower that
we got at the grocery store like the
shrinkflation is real as well and we
were talking before we went live just
about how silly I think like the
archivist disputes are like I said in
September probably every one of these
presidential vice presidential libraries
and think tanks in America is out of
some sort of technical compliance with
the records keeping act and for my
constituents who have to drive a long
way to work and are looking at gas
prices who if you want to buy a used car
today I mean good luck I mean it's I
don't know if you want to drive them or
bronze them after you get them based on
how much you have to pay the housing
market rent being up uh so high I mean
already we made it where Millennials can
barely afford to to buy a house so so
many are forced into rental life and now
what's happening with the cost of rent
you know those are things that I think
like people really think about and you
turn on cable news and it's all about
like there's an 11th document that they
have found in Joe Biden's convertibles
glove compartment and we're supposed to
clutch our pearls and act like that's
like the biggest thing on the planet
Earth the 1.7 trillion Omnibus that went
through a cup was about a month ago
three weeks ago that changed the value
of the dollar doing the math 1.7
trillion to our 31 trillion deficit is
uh or debt is uh took the value of the
dollar from one dollar to 95 cents like
every dollar that you have is now worth
95 cents because that bill passed or be
that yes yes because that money was
printed I should say yeah and you can go
you know recap the value if you go to
the gender studies courses in Pakistan
exactly and I think the financial
problem is going to be very significant
I I think a lot of people saw it uh
during the beginning of covid uh I
personally was calling it out but but we
still haven't seen the full
ramifications of it there's there's
going to be a lot of responsibility when
it comes to printing so much money
spending so much money that we don't
have what are you seeing down the
pipeline how do you think this is going
to unfold some people are saying uh in
the corporate media that this is going
to be just a little temporary recession
I don't think so myself how do you see
it unfolding yeah it just it it seems as
though we haven't yet paid the full
price in jobs for what we've done to the
dollar and you're starting to see that
with you know all the what I call the
hoodie layoffs right all the tech
companies laying off people by the
thousands but now we're starting to see
it in the productive sectors of the
economy too in manufacturing in
agriculture stuff's just not creating
the same investment confidence it's not
attracting the same degree of capital
now fortunately a lot of other places in
the world are have it worse than we do
so the dollar you know has not has not
bottomed out but we cannot drive
government spending to this extent and
so then it becomes like okay in this
world of divided government what fight
do you pick to try to resolve that and
we got the debt limit coming up and
Republicans typically lose fights over
the debt limit if you just look
politically historically because you
know we're talking about some sort of
economic algebra problem and the
Democrats are like yeah well your 401k
will get cut in half you know if this
doesn't happen if the Republicans do
brinksmanship so as that comes up like
what is the thing that we demand to
spend less money on and I would
represent that work requirements would
be the right fight like we send a s we
send so much money right now to
able-bodied people who could work but
choose not to and we do it through State
programs that Access Federal drawdowns
we do it through Medicaid expansion we
do it through different features of
Obamacare voluntary Pre-K although all
those different social service programs
and if you had work requirements in
order to access those for able-bodied
people then I think that would be
anti-inflationary that would reduce some
of the mandatory spending and the
entitlement spending and I think people
could get that right as opposed to just
like trying to walk everybody through an
economic X pie chart as the Democrats
are accusing us of brinksmanship so with
the economy tanking can you please give
us some Insider Congressional trading
tips please so that's enough by the way
another area where the populist right
and populists left should work together
I do not believe that members of
Congress should trade individual stocks
we have information that other people do
not and we have the ability to impact
how various companies do based on the
types of programs we authorize or uh or
that we pull and so it's just crazy to
me that that was ever allowed and uh
you're talking about you know big Tech
bills and like potentially breaking up
Facebook and just imagine if you're
about to even vote on that and then you
go and you know put option and get put
options that's not a hypothetical that
happened I mean we had bills that were
moving through the Judiciary Committee
that passed out of the Judiciary
Committee that broke up big Tech and we
were all getting ready for them to come
to the floor and on the dip Paul Pelosi
bought a bunch of those stocks wow and
then guess what guess what Tim they
never [ __ ] came to the floor wow what
a surprise these people are evil what
that's like what they did about Napoleon
the British where they said Napoleon
lost the war or won the war everyone
sold their British stock a bunch of rich
British businessmen bought it up and
they're like actually he's still
fighting so you're saying go long or
short on Tesla I'm taking them someone
needs a clip that Paul Pelosi thing and
put it on Twitter have you guys talked
about like defaulting on the Federal
Reserve debt and just telling this
private quasi-private public company
like we're not your [ __ ] we are you
work for us we allow you to exist and
we're not we can't pay debt that we
don't have you borrow 10 trillion
dollars you can't pay back 15. you only
have 10. we ain't got it we take a
post-dated check yeah like because we're
talking about like where are we going to
get the money if we for the debt ceiling
thing like what about we just don't ever
want to be your landlord you know what
the answer is I don't have it I'm all
about small business but I do feel like
it's like how do I get this parasite out
of my brain without killing myself the
Federal Reserve like it's it's in our
system right now it has been in control
since 1913 but like what and they had
one job and it was not to let the
economy overheat so that we got to this
level of inflation and they did it in
1928 right it happened in 28 I mean the
Great Depression was a direct result of
these banksters you know deciding when
and how we can run our our lives so does
that ever come up do you guys talk a lot
about the Federal Reserve and and
breaking it up or just take Congress
taking control of the monetary Supply
well in in our life time you've seen
Congress devolve more power than it has
claimed and so in a lot of ways it's a
way for members of Congress to avoid a
great deal of accountability for the
economy to just act as though it's a
bunch of nerds with green eye shades at
the FED that turn dials up or down that
cause the economy to react in various
ways so the answer is no damn and it's
because they don't want to get stuck
with the bag if and when the economy
actually does crash uh well I I mean I
think that's reprehensible because
that's the one of the sole jobs of
Congress is to protect the monetary
Supply
well and instead you get the 1.7
trillion dollar Omni which is why this
fight we had this last week matters
because it's only ever going to be the
way it's going to be until you force
change and until you use the leverage
you have and like think about it if a
republican was President I would have
never been able to pull off what what we
pulled off because people have said oh
like you're getting in the way of the
Trump agenda or the you know the bush
agenda or whatever but because Biden was
there Schumer was in the Senate like
there wasn't this intense pressure to
organize the house immediately and we
had the ability to be more deliberative
and to get the structural concessions to
stop that and to regain that power you
mentioned earlier how you guys were like
kind of working at the populists were
working together and then January 6
comes along and we talk about like who
let those people into that door like who
who hit the magnetic unlock and like let
those people walk in from the inside and
now we're seeing because of January 6
the populist right and the populace left
are at odds it's as if division was sown
by whom I don't know but for some reason
because of this event that happened
where people were let into that freaking
building by some people now there's now
we have Congressional division which
didn't seem similar with Occupy Wall
Street we were all there together to
elaborate on that talk about the FED
section you talked about this a year ago
the January 6th we we already know based
on The Whistleblower interviews that
we've done that there were federal
agents and federal assets that were on
the ground that day and what we don't
know is the extent to which any of those
assets or agents increase the level of
criminal Acuity coordinated with one
another or purposefully entrapped folks
who were otherwise not wanting to hurt
anyone or violate any law in some sort
of technical violation of trespassing or
uh Crossing some barrier that had
existed hours earlier but that had been
taken down and
it's noteworthy to me that it's been the
Department of Justice fighting tooth and
nail against the release of a lot of the
documentary evidence that would answer
these questions and who was raps
rayaps is an is the only person involved
in January 6 that Adam kinsinger will
continuously defend isn't that something
and why I mean I think a lot of people
have assumptions he's somehow connected
with FEDS or he may be testified or
something well I just don't there's no
rational explanation for how this guy is
sending out message saying he
orchestrated the activity is at every
critical point he's like the Forrest
Gump of the January 6th string of events
right and then when
you're able to isolate the people that
are pulled off of the FBI's Most Wanted
lists and the people who
you know seem to be encouraging others
and moving others that like it's like
you know Ray Epps did nothing so they'll
go and like raid the home of some like
couple in Homer Alaska because they
think they have Nancy Pelosi's laptop
but this guy who's at the center of the
action it's like nothing to see here so
you know I I am troubled by the
disparate treatment that EPS gets
compared to like some you know
grandmother that wandered past a
barricade that then is facing some
intense criminal process from doj I'm
concerned that those people in detention
are becoming radicalized just by being
forgotten and left to rot like do you
know what the status is of these people
that have been in prison well we've
gotten
varying reports on that and not nearly
enough information and a lot of them
have been deprived of just like basic
civil rights when it comes to the
adversarial judicial process one thing
I'm investigating right now is the
extent to which the public defenders
that were assigned to a lot of these
folks like hated them and wanted the
book thrown at them and were posting on
social media and texting their friends
you know about the the nature of those
proceedings so that's a big area of
concern for me how they were treated in
prison uh and in jail in the DC jail in
particular I went there it was pretty
crazy I went there and they were like
locked us out of being able to do an
inspection and that's unprecedented for
a member of Congress to not have the
ability to inspect a facility that is
under the control of the federal
government at some level could you go to
Guantanamo when that was open is it
still still could yeah if you got if you
got the plane we could go tonight that's
hard get an authentic mojito oh I'm so
into it have you been there before I
don't want to go to gitmo you crazy
you ever see the meme that said
waterboarding at Guantanamo Bay sounds
really fun if you don't know what it is
yeah horrible
yeah no thank you what are you trying to
set me up here Ian yeah man bring your
camera I don't know are you allowed to
bring a camera inside there there's a
number of these cases where people were
engaged in journalism and are facing
charges that are more kin to
Insurrection like people who are there
trying to film and capture the event and
then you know are getting multi-year
prison sentences it's just like there's
been there's been 950 people charged so
far but the doj is saying that the
investigation is far from over and
recently through a a congressional bill
they even got more funding and they're
saying that they're going to be doubling
the amount of people that they already
arrested
um and and talk about how these
specialized units that have FBI CIA that
were targeted at extremism in you know
Afghanistan Iraq Yemen you know all over
the world that now those very same teams
and those very same tools and those very
same National Security authorities are
exclusively being turned inward you know
to instead instead of finding you know
somebody that's building a bomb to blow
up an embassy abroad they're like you
know analyzing what some guy who lives
in his mom's basement is putting on his
blog that's read by tens of people and
then the and that now after they were
turned inward as a result of this
Omnibus spending legislation they are
flooded with cash I mean just so much
money that is now in the hands of these
people who wake up every day saying you
know how can I go find a white
supremacist extremist to hunt down and
you know if if you create an industry of
witch Hunters right like you're going to
find more witches like even if they're
not actually witches and as you
mentioned in the beginning of this
broadcast this was originally created
this industry was created by George W
bush it was created by the Republicans
right after 9 11 passing the Patriot Act
allowing Homeland Security to do
whatever they want allowed allowing the
TSA to touch you wherever they wanted to
and and I think this is why there needs
to be a bigger call out of this old
Republican guard of these neocons that
created this situation that's literally
being turned around and used against the
American people the war on terror is now
the war on America and it's the
intelligency it's the intelligence
agency's waging it against American
citizens which is great we have to have
the guts to repeal those authorities and
the thing is anytime you get any
momentum behind any effort to do that
you get the neoconservatives running in
saying well you're going to be the
reason there's another 911. and then
people fold yeah oh my gosh sounds like
a threat more than anything else yeah
well it just it is a way to test
people's will and the will often does
not rise to the occasion that's why
these authorities don't get curtailed
purely because the people are afraid
that they'll be become I mean honestly I
could see why because if something did
happen then they might feel good but
like uh all right this is gonna take
another couple hours to talk about I
don't think we're gonna be able to
finish this one right now all right do
you do you repeal the Patriot Act well
do you have the power to actually put a
stop to this j6 nonsense
unilaterally no the house won't have the
power to do that uh I do believe that
substantial elements of the National
Security apparatus and these these
prosecutions need to be defunded do I
think there's a critical mass of
Republicans who are willing to shut down
the government over it no but we have to
go make our case and and the thing we
got to do is like build the deterrent
against it like a lot of these folks in
for all their tough talk and for all
they're willing to do when they have
anonymity when you drag them before the
country and ask them tough questions as
I've done with some of the leading
figures in the National Security State
before the Judiciary Committee they
don't like that too much and when you do
it to a few of them the rest of them get
adrift and see that and you know that
works to a point but it it pales when
you compare it to these Exquisite
authorities that have been turned Inward
and then the extreme resourcing of them
that we have just seen so we need like a
we need the population to speak up and
start making noise about repealing the
Patriot Act I I think that the patriarch
was a terrible mistake for our country
and I would I would advocate for its
repeal are there things so esoteric you
know how do you convince you know I'll
put it this way we were talking earlier
about how you mentioned Ian Dave Smith's
thing that if you want to see who we're
going to go up against next look at who
we're funding now
we fund Ukraine we fund as of in 20
years we may be fighting them like we
did with the mujahideen and then the
Taliban Al-Qaeda et cetera Afghanistan
but the kids who vote in favor of those
Wars the people right now the young
people who are liberals who are voting
for you know this policy weren't alive
when these when we were funding these
these groups right like I think I was a
baby when the muja Deen stuff was
happening and so then I'm 20 years old I
vote you know I was 18 I don't know how
they was I vote for Obama and then he's
just continuing the cycle of war against
who we had just been funding with
Ukraine give it 20 years some young
person is going to be like gotta vote
Democrat they're the ones who are
fighting against these evil Nazis the
difference they're the ones who funded
it that's the good thing though now is
there's so much media on this that it
may be Unforgettable in the
Consciousness I mean obviously there's
being manipulated to show you one or the
other you know way of looking at the
situation but people that are six may be
very well aware of what's happening in
Ukraine when they're 18. as opposed to
in Iraq 2003 there's no internet video
so or very little well in the 90s there
wasn't I mean other than maybe Pat
Buchanan and a few of his buddies there
wasn't a a an anti-war segment of the
political right with any actual power
right and I think that it's because the
millennial generation has grown weary of
this I mean all of our lives our country
has been in some state of low yield war
and we see that people come back with
broken Limbs and broken hearts and
broken Minds we see the effect on
marriages the drug abuse the suicide and
we start to see the real cost of it and
now on the right there are people
willing to ask tough questions about
these things and and that scrutiny just
didn't exist on a lot of these other
Misadventures if only we would have
listened to Ron Paul when when you were
young you still can when uh when like
the Patriot Act was getting voted on
stuff were you like a young conservative
yeah I think I I adhered to a lot of the
kind of Republican thinking on those
things I I thought Bush was a great
president initially and then you know as
I as I started to see in my heavily
military Community the impacts of these
wars I just thought like man like
trading a bunch of sand dunes around in
Iraq like isn't worth like Chris's dad
not having legs wow you know and you see
that over and over and it impacts you
and not only that these interventions
also created more future conflicts it
not only allowed Iran to have more of a
sphere of influence in the region but
because we we went in there and
overthrew the government we created Isis
in so many different ways is by
incentivizing that group to start up
there and to also hand over a lot of
American Military technology and and
weapons right directly into their hands
giving us a new enemy to fight and use
them as ponzo to overthrow I told Trump
is that it was all no matter what the
policy area was it was always the
neocons that stabbed him in the
background you know if you just wanted
to take like a crude uh way to triage
like the people that stabbed him in the
back that were part of his own
Administration it was always the neocons
why did you think he kept coming to them
asking them for hugs all the time and
giving them all these lucrative
positions of power I want to ask
something for the audience a lot of
people are asking about the ATF passing
a new role on pistol braces do you see
this Luke they're they're gonna they're
they're saying they're NFA items now
basically they're banning them I'm
curious uh abolish the ATF what do you
think yeah I mean Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms is just what we call a good
Saturday night in my district or it
should be the name of a store or not you
know an agency no I mean it there is a
deep State at the ATF I mean no doubt
and during the Trump Administration it
was actually pretty bad there a lot of
the rules that they were passing were
converting people into criminals who had
no intention of violating the law
whatsoever
honestly don't even think that you
should be able to like seriously debate
gun legislation if you're not from an
SEC State you know when I see like the
northeasterners you know get all worked
up and they don't know anything about
Firearms they haven't used Firearms they
haven't stored Firearms it's quite
comical to see like David sicilini from
Rhode Island or you know was it they
Thomas Massey asked Jerry Nadler of New
York like what does the AR stand for in
AR-15 and Nadler said assault rifles
what's SEC States like the Southeastern
Conference you know Georgia Florida
Mississippi Tennessee Arkansas well you
got New Hampshire up there too in New
Hampshire and West Virginia West
Virginia's constitutional carry yeah I
don't know if it matters it's 9 14. did
you want to honestly I was I felt bad
for the audience because I knew I was
going to cough a bunch so I thought by
now it would be full coffee I can barely
sound good to me I mean all right if
they're if they'll hang with me you'll
hang out oh dudes people are people are
loving it they're so excited I don't
know if Luke if you wanted to like if
you saw any specific questions in the
super chats because a lot of people are
bringing up the ATF thing um because
essentially what they're calling for is
going to make a lot of Americans
felons just like the kind of bump stock
ban that passed through Donald Trump
that was just ruled unconstitutional so
other than the courts is there any way
to effectively Lobby the ATF is there
any way to stop them from from
essentially making legal law-abiding
citizens felons overnight one tool that
we got in these negotiations over the
speaker of the house is the
reinstitution of something called the
Homan rule where you can zero out the
funding for a particular bureaucrat so
like imagine if you could have just
isolated like fauci's salary and zeroed
it out and forced a vote on that
couldn't do that before you're now going
to be able to do that I suspect that
some of us in the Second Amendment
caucus will be visiting the uh the
bureaucrats at the ATF with that tool
Holmen
oh man we didn't even talk about fauci
see is he well loved in Congress is it
divisive what's what's his next gig
University president big Pharma CEO
podcast is going to be the CEO of Pfizer
how can he not right yep yep something
like that yeah would you hire fauci if
you knew that no matter what job it was
he was going to be spending like
20 hours a week in Congressional
depositions I think he got a deal I'd be
willing to bet like so many of these
other uh officials who have this with
you know within this revolving door
system he probably cut a deal a long
time ago that when he's out they'll pick
him up speaking of the revolving door
another one of the like ethics things
that I just don't understand how it's
not the law now if you are a member of
Congress you should never get to be a
lobbyist or a registered foreign agent
but it is like two of the most frequent
jobs that people get when they're done
with the job I have is literally being a
registered agent for a foreign
government or influencing people for
money and I don't I don't get why it's
not like a total Common Sense thing to
say like you've got to choose one path
or the other like you if you want to go
be a foreign agent if you want to get
paid money to influence outcomes then
that means you don't get to be one of
the lawmakers yeah yeah I believe it was
Joe Rogan a couple months ago was
interviewing someone that was making the
claim that members of Congress were
getting different kind of treatment for
kovid than the rest of the general
public was do you know if that's
particularly true I know we talked about
this yeah um do you remember who the
guest was because I can't remember that
off the top of my head right now but
that was the accusation is that
accusation true that Congress gets a
different kind of Health Care system
than the American people do when it came
to covet nah man we're like most of us
are on the DC Obamacare Exchange
so you got Obamacare is it not Obama did
you get code what's up with this I hear
like members of Congress sleeping in
their office yeah uh more than a hundred
of the 435 members of Congress when
they're in uh Washington DC actually
live inside of their office and I did
that until I met my now wife and she
made it very clear that that was not an
arrangement that she was going to be
tolerant of just because they want to
save money uh it's it's the money uh I
mean a lot you know though no one should
ever worry about members of Congress in
our economic standing I mean people who
have you know maybe a spouse that
doesn't work that's raising a family you
know maintaining two residences on a
congressional salary is challenging for
some people I uh I mostly like Airbnb it
uh because uh I have the like Yasser
Arafat theory that you never want to
sleep in the same bed twice what's this
what's this what's this thing I'm
hearing that y'all are getting a 34 000
raise is that true
uh no one's told me that there was an
article in the daily mail that said that
one of the last things the Democrats did
before the end of the last session was
put in a raise of thirty four thousand
dollars I'm unaware of any race if
that's true the Margaritas are on me
after the show Elon Musk probably is
going to like to hear that the members
of Congress are sleeping in their own
office uh but there's a lot of rodent
activity at night too because they're
always working on that building wow
there you go man to ask you about this
could give could give oh yeah no that's
a that's a per diem uh there's Congress
was like weirdly cut out of the GSA per
diem and so that would allow Congress to
access the the GSA per die which is like
while you're working away from home
you're that'll be your budget right so
if like if I bring an employee from
Pensacola up to Washington to work on a
legislative issue for a week they get a
per diem but we don't so this would
equalize I was going to ask you what do
you think about what Elon Musk is doing
with Twitter and do you think there's
going to be any kind of Retribution
against them since he did expose how
essentially the intelligence agencies
were pretty much running big Tech social
media is there going to be like some
bureaucratic investigations are they
going to try to take away some of his
funding from some of his spaceships how
do you think that's you already saw
Chris Murphy call for reviews of the
different foreign investors in the musk
Twitter deal so it's not a question of
if that will happen that that is
happening now it's just a question of
the level of Acuity of it and and you
know there's so many of my Republican
colleagues are like yeah you know
Twitter's ours now Elon bought Twitter
rah-rah you know wave the pom-poms for
Elon and I'm glad he bought it I'm glad
Twitter's more of a democratized free
speech speech space but like is this
what we is this what we have to wait for
that we have to wait around for
something like right-wing billionaire to
come buy stuff so that we can have a
playground I just don't want to live in
a world where the terms of service on
social media become more important than
the values that undergird the
constitution yeah it's a cultural
question though right it just seems like
it seems so low T to sit around and
cheer on Elon well like we are the board
of directors the most powerful country
in the world and we do nothing while the
digital Marketplace of ideas is Zapped
of any conservative thought
yeah I don't think relying on any one
guy is the right move it's weight
because his emotions can change his
behavior we say he wouldn't let Alex
Jones back on because he's like no I
don't like what he said about kids about
Sandy Hook's stuff like uh
uh John Astor started a story in New
York I mean he just bought the entire I
don't know the exact history but because
of one billionaire or whatever he was
worth we have Astoria and like we have
communities like one rich guy can build
a community it's a little culty but it's
kind of like the history of our of our
species I don't know if we need that
like I think that we can legislate away
the problems sometimes but a lot of
times I think it's in the private sector
I don't know like the government's
really good what I really love the
government for is to tell us when
something has gone too far and to stop
it from happening as opposed to making
all these things happen all the time
like that's up for the populace today
yeah but wouldn't you agree that
these tech companies getting more power
than most of the governments that have
ever existed in all of human history is
that threshold where they've gone too
far yes yes it's gone too far it needs
to be broken up in a way that I I think
needs to be novel that's right so then
the dispute amongst some working on the
issue is do you use like the force of
law to break them up or do you like
almost do what happened to the tobacco
companies in the 90s where you strip
their immunities and then sick the trial
lawyers on them but they're still
they're still acting in the benefit of a
lot of government agents I don't see
them being put in check until they stop
actually taking the orders from
government and not doing what the
government really wants them to do
um
litigating against them in court want
their next job to be at Big Tech you
know I mean the revolving door is kind
of a consistent theme of our of our
discussion today but look at how many
people go working from from FBI doj CIA
NSA and their next job is in Silicon
Valley it's a huge percentage Yeah if
you remove the the immunities of what
they did in tobacco companies then
you're thinking maybe the or or might
what happened is they won't prosecute
properly because they want to get jobs
there even if they don't have what I've
seen so far is that the folks at doj
want to be like just enough of a
parasite that never kills the host so
you know they want to be just enough of
a pain where they maximize their own
economic value to then go and work for
the big tech companies afterwards
man that's a good question would we use
the government to break it up or just
strip their immunity and let the law
take take this course and this is the
issue that Jim Jordan and I disagree on
you know guy as we've talked about I
have tremendous respect for but he
prefers more of a Judicial route and I
prefer more of a legislative route I I
prefer the government stop controlling
big Tech social media and stop
manipulating the platform for their own
personal benefit that's me and I think
if we stop that and and we also have to
understand the government allowed these
companies to have a monopoly on the
market there's no way to even compete
against them because of the unfair
advantage that they got from members of
Congress and and and whether it's tax
incentives whether it's Google Maps
getting the data from the US military
there's there's so much of of them just
working hand in hand that I don't even
see the big difference between you know
big Tech social media and the government
sometimes to be honest with you well big
Tech is so owned by someone like
government at least is we the people but
I I do but they're still acting like a
vehicle or is it a private
is it is it still we the people with
government
I I think members of Congress should
have to wear the patches of their pack
and lobbyist donors like NASCAR drivers
have to wear their sponsors yeah I think
Bill Hicks made that joke uh originally
and he was prophetic and I absolutely
agree with him 100 we should do like an
augmented reality VR app or ar app where
you put on the glasses and you can see
like the augmented reality of all the
donors on other clubs you can see the
lobby standing behind them yeah with
their hands on there like in an aura
just like floating above you see like
big Pharma big Tech defense contractors
that's actually a joke meme that came
out but is very very should should be
like on their desk you should see all
the all the people that have donated to
their behavior because they're supposed
to represent their 700 000 constituents
the most insulting thing when you go try
to persuade someone to change their
Viewpoint or to develop their Viewpoint
and they literally refer you to the
lobbyists like I've had that happen with
colleagues where I'm like hey look I
really want to talk to you about this
insurance issue and they're like okay
great as soon as I hear from the State
Farm in all state lobbyists that like
your change is an appropriate one then I
can be with you that sounds like
you mentioned before the show that
people pay each other for sponsorship
well I was discussing the dynamic on the
house floor so on the floor of the House
of Representatives members enjoy broad
immunities as a consequence of the
speech and debate clause and giving each
other political donations to campaigns
is permissible on the floor and so I
mean you can observe Dynamics where
someone is
in one sentence soliciting your Vote or
co-sponsorship and then in the very next
sentence is talking is handing you a
check so so they don't directly say like
hey I'll give you money if you vote for
me they'll say thanks for voting for me
by the way here's two thousand dollars
oh yeah Tim I'd really really like you
to consider co-sponsoring this
legislation it's real important to me
and I know that you've got a fundraiser
coming up tonight so here I wanted to
just come right to the floor and give
you a check for it so they can't
specifically say vote for this money is
so that you vote for me they can't do
that specifically but they can be like
thanks for voting for me here's money
yeah it's always with uh with a bit of
uh winking a nod wow are we still in
control the government the people what's
your Vibe that's what I'm that's what
I'm saying well look what do you think
we were doing this last week you think
it was the most comfortable thing in the
world for 20 of us to try to send a
shockwave through the DC cartel and say
it's not just going to go the way it's
always been and we shouldn't we
shouldn't just move people forward in a
system that
to its core is fundamentally corrupt
with both parties no we wanted we
thought it should be about the policy
the procedure and the Personnel not just
the distribution of funds and the
alliances that creates and for that we
were called the Taliban 20. we were
called the Insurgency caucus and that
was members of our own party that wasn't
even what the other party was calling us
outside of McCarthy do you fear
retaliation in any other sense like
there's a machine at play and you're
you're throwing a a wrench in the spokes
I I you know I swim fine in turbulent
Waters so I personally I don't but I we
all watch out for each other you know if
someone were to retaliate against one of
my colleagues who might have less
notoriety I would be there to have their
back and I I would Marshal every force
that we have to ensure that that did not
happen against the people that showed
courage but
but I mean politically I mean just
politics can be a dirty game Tim Google
me it's pretty hard to say worse things
about me than they already have and when
you sort of have faced that down and
taken their best shot it builds calluses
to become enduring and valuable in the
next fight I'm sure it actually kind of
pissed you off and made you push 10
times harder liberating in a way you
know when I was watching the McCarthy
fight you know my attitude was like the
more I heard these stories where he was
just like smugly rejecting you guys I'm
like that probably made him Double Down
well we knew what we wanted
we knew what our goals were and
oftentimes like there are people in
Congress who just want to be in the
fight for being in
for the sake of being in the fight like
as an end unto itself but we knew we had
to get out of this system uh a a result
that would prohibit the passage of an
another Omnibus and once we knew that we
were able to really direct a lot of our
our strategic decisions toward that goal
didn't they like bring the Omnibus like
two years ago on like a wagon they like
wheeled in it was like 5 000 Pages
nobody read that it's crazy that and I'm
like who wrote it
well I mean the lobbyists wrote it
literally like lawyers
who do you think writes his stuff
the lobbyists come and bring it to
members members slap their name on it it
goes into the system that should be
illegal and they never read it they
don't even know what's in the bill in
many times they try to read them and
there's many stories of people sneaking
in stuff last minute and it becoming
lost I mean it can't we can't make it
illegal to be a lobbyist because people
have a First Amendment right but they're
right for someone else no but that's
that is a function of petitioning your
government to me what's so offensive is
that like when you've got the former
chairman of these committees who hired
all the staff that then roll out of
their chairmanship go right to K Street
and then are lobbying the people they
hired we the people aren't in charge the
highest bidder is in charge in a system
like that fair point then so what do we
do
well I think we need broad ethics
reforms and the only way we get them is
by uniting the populist right and the
populace left
there's no reason why we shouldn't be
working with the squad on a stock ban on
a stock trading ban there's no reason we
shouldn't be working with leftists on
um Banning members of Congress from
becoming foreign agents or lobbyists and
people have got to get over their egos
people have to know you know that uh you
know they got a
get over January 6th or whatever it
takes but that to me that's the path
is it possible right now you think I
kind of it's never been more possible
because we get individual votes on stuff
when you don't get individual votes
there's no accountability Now by house
rule there have to be individual votes
and the other thing is that our
amendments have to be made in order if
we go get 20 of the house to sign on to
an amendment and that amendment is
germane to the bill it gets a vote and
some like little group of some College
of cardinals in the rules committee
doesn't get to prohibit members from
taking votes on those issues and there
are some who are in the very purple
seats who are going to be uncomfortable
about that because they're gonna have to
take a lot more votes than they might
want to take but that is what the job
requires I want to go to super chats but
I asked the audience a poll I said is
Matt Gates the best member of Congress
85 said yes so there you go my mom wants
the IP addresses of the other 15
um but Luke do you want to do Luke and
Ian do you guys want to read super chats
picks up I don't have them I don't have
them pulled up Ian do you have them
pulled I can go through just from the
YouTube page itself elf yeah uh let's
start off with David Berg this is a this
is one this is from like more more
recent to to older which is the the
reverse of what we normally do but David
said David Berg from Destin Florida
could not be more proud of my
congressman Matt Gates you did what we
elected you to do uh it's great to hear
from one of my actual bosses in in
Destin that's in my district thanks
David yeah let's keep taking these
yeah I remember when I first got here
they like the leadership sat me down in
one of these like uh I don't know if you
can touch Uncle talks and said uh well
Gates you're just not a team player and
I said no like I'm a great team player
it's just that you all are not my team
my team are the 750 000 people who look
you sent me here from Florida search try
to find one as well I got one here from
GOP gamer who asks can Congress label
the ATF a state-sponsored terror
organization dogs everywhere will thank
you so that's a that's a Super Chat by
GOP gamer and uh surge pick up pick up
the next one uh give me no no that's a
question you know if anyone wants to
answer all right can it be a state
sponsor of term let's just defund it
let's just let's just isolate the
bureaucrats there that make the bad
decisions zero out their salaries and
take away their authorities I'd like to
isolate bureaucrats thing it's kind of
like sanctions on and on on a opposing
and an enemy and think about you don't
have to do it to all of them you do it
to a few and it has a strong deterrent
effect on the rest that if they are
promulgating some rule or advancing
something that is indefensible we're
going to make them a star sloppy DMT Joe
has a super chat that is asking
legalized DMT question mark
I mean I've been for legalizing a lot
but I don't know what is that
dimethyltryptamine is um it's a chemical
in your body that's basically kind of
responsible for the dream state that we
live in this whole like dream of reality
versus you know like and uh it's
secreted in your your body uh plants
things but people in modern culture will
get it out of Ayahuasca have you you're
familiar with the Ayahuasca Vine not
personally I I have friends who swear by
it but any drug that has it like a
predicate that you like vomit and [ __ ]
yourself is really not the type of
experience I sign up for that's why you
do fasting for a week beforehand because
you're really just purging crap here's
the next important question uh should
American citizens have the right to own
nuclear weapons and biological weapons
no you don't think I think they should
well should is the wrong answer is that
what that Silo was that I walked by on
the way here the two silos you mean oh
man no what I mean to say is not should
is that uh the Second Amendment says
arms if if you don't think that's the
case then we gotta amend the Second
Amendment because when they wrote it
that private seers existed and they had
weapons of they had the equip like they
had weapons of war to an extreme degree
they had you know uh frigates and man of
war privateers corsairs Etc so I don't
see how we've decided at some point
outside of the Constitution that certain
weapons are off limit to the people when
they originally weren't you see what I
mean yeah I understand nuclear weapons
then no I get it I mean definitely if
that were gonna start it would be in
Florida I mean the Florida man would be
the first wasn't there a guy like who
was uh taking a maricium and he was
making he made a death ray I think that
was in Florida wasn't it I could be
wrong
we got another uh uh Super Chat By Dana
Costello who's asking what does Matt
feel about auditing the Federal Reserve
I'm for it I'm on Massey's Bill to do
that
Massey picked that up from uh from Ron
Paul and I support it and actually every
Congress we got more people on that bill
that's awesome search you got one uh
yeah I got one uh Matt what is being
done to curtail the Federal Reserves
rapid March towards Weimar Germany style
inflation uh what is America's breaking
points from uh hiatusobo
yeah it's a great question because you
know the
like the grover NorQuest view of
conservatism was that if we could just
cut taxes enough you could kind of
starve the Beast right and that is
proven false because we've we've been
pretty successful at stopping
large-scale tax increases but we've
substituted fed policy for it and by the
way mnuchin was one of the worst like if
you look at what happened during covet
and all of the different fed policy that
was constructed then that is badly in
need of audit and was undeniably abused
in a number of cases and so yeah I mean
I I think that the FED failed and it's
one one job it's only directive yeah of
pushing against inflation and uh
it's yet another institution that
continues to have less and less Trust
we got another five dollar Super Chat
from David Troutman he says please don't
cancel tomorrow I'm driving up from
Charlotte with guitars to play with for
you guys tomorrow was not canceled but
Luke and Ian are too lazy to get up on
time
I feel assaulted that early unnecessary
they're doing a meet up tomorrow at 10
o'clock in the morning in Washington DC
so I got one here Mr Claire from Kevin
Malone an Insurrection yeah it's gonna
be insurrectingly good time uh will
there be a zero-based balanced budget
amendment
uh we will have a budget that balances
over 10 years that all members will have
to vote on uh I think we should have the
balanced budget amendment vote with that
and we and we may how do you balance a
budget with inflation clawing up the
back of our necks because like I don't
know what
the or I should say with the interest
with interest right right but they're
related right because as
you have the interest rates increase
that the cost of that Debt Service
balloons and then that eats up a greater
and greater share of the budget and it's
not discretionary you have to do it so
do you just
but how how do we pay off the interest
to the Federal Reserve how much of
actually this is a real question how
much debt of the debt that we owe to
Federal Reserve is interest was accrued
by interest and how much of it is base
principle I used to know this but I
don't know okay because the rates have
changed
um but but I I uh like look the drivers
of the debt
the interest on the debt Social Security
Medicare Medicaid and so if you're not
willing to attack Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid from an
eligibility standpoint or a benefit
standpoint
you're counting number of angels on the
head of a pin I used to be like you know
people are sick pay for their health
care and now I'm like I watch people
just continually drink poison and eat
poison I'm like I can't keep paying
money to keep those people alive the
thing that I don't get is why we
subsidize the stuff that makes people
sick like what we allow food stamps to
pay for poisons people and so we pay to
like get people into this like diabetic
State then they get disabled then we put
them on SSID then in the final you know
six months of Life the the curve on the
cost on spending on their health care
goes through the roof and we do it all
over again and you know why because
sugar companies and Candy confectioners
and big food get in there and ensure
that we never reduce the amount of
unhealthy stuff that we pay for for poor
people as well as the subsidies for corn
and soy which help create seed oils but
that's another thing we got another 20
Super Chat from AJ that is asking aside
from fauci the public would like to see
an investigation by the how house into
Klaus Schwab the world economic Forum
Soros and Gates make it happen Matt
winky face that's the 20 Super Chat well
let me let me let me Flip Flip that on
you guys I mean you know
all right the the weaponization against
the American people select subcommittee
meets for the first meeting
who's your first Witness
for what was the question so so so we've
we've asked that that is a con that is a
very popular choice right now among some
Republicans now the Dems then get to
take their shots at him because though
we're not we're not like the you know
Liz Cheney Benny Thompson thing we'll
put actual Democrats on the Committees
because we want to have real debate but
uh Elon would be
a stellar first Witness
wow
witness for what I'm sorry I was looking
at the foundation of media yeah yeah I
mean because because you get all of the
features of the weaponization of our
government through the Twitter files you
get the National Security piece you get
the white house uh officials trying to
get information you know either enhanced
or diminished on Twitter uh so you could
open a lot of doors through that you get
the dod think about that how the dod was
involved in different like foreign
policy narratives
I think he'd gladly do it he'd be like
yup tell me when to come talk yeah
that's a good one uh Sean Young has a 50
Super Chat asking why is it criminal to
lie when testifying before Congress but
not criminal to lie when you are holding
a seat in Congress
well tradition mostly
I see we got another uh ten dollar Super
Chat by gunface 11 saying can you
abolish the NFA
we could
we won't but I mean we have the powers
Ian search yeah yeah let's do this one
uh oh wait did I read this one all right
here we go this one's actually kind of
nice although it's sad
um Divine interventions is there
anything that can be done at all is
there any hope sounds like we're just
going to end up in a dystopian
dictatorship like China by the end of
the decade I'm severely black pilled
it
who was that that's Divine interventions
divine intervention yeah there's uh
there's some tension between the uh the
name and the sentiment that's expressed
there
um you know I encountered this actually
pretty frequently at our town halls and
rallies where people show up and say you
know I came because I think you're
fighting for us but
so there are some who think it's it's
kind of all lost and whenever I get down
you know Jim Jordan is uh is a guy who
gives me Comfort when he says look
there's always a fight worth having in
this place like I have a job in the
United States Congress where there there
are dozens of files on my desk every
morning where it's someone who relies on
me to to pick up their cause and to go
to battle for it and if that can't get
you up and that can't get you focused on
being the best version of yourself then
nothing can so that stops me from
getting black pill because you know
whether it's getting a little old lady
or IRS check that she was supposed to
get and they screwed her over whether
it's the guy who has 22 EPA agents show
up because he wanted to expand his
cattle Pond
um you know and you're able to
get them off his back
um or whether it's one of our service
members that now we have to advocate for
so that they can get their careers and
their lives back after this foolish
vaccine mandate was repealed you know
there are still good things to do and
good people that that deserve us to be
focused and not so diminished or
discouraged that that we don't get in
get in the fight for them okay yeah we
got uh they got two real fast got uh fat
bar muja who says Matt Gates rocks which
is a good one there's a lot a lot of
people congratulating you and thank you
by the way in the chat and the super
chats as well and then the second one uh
Matt if the IRS abolition fails about
abolishment fails we need you to end all
uh yeah we need you to move to end all
federal withholding make people realize
the tax that they pay and quarterly
payments and make them pay once a year
this is the way to change things in
regards to taxes in the IRS that's a key
leverage point the withholding
absolutely is let me ask you guys this
question so the house gets in our first
bill
abolish 87 000 IRS agents but like we
know that that has no chance of a
hearing in the Senate it's never going
to get signed by Joe Biden and so
how we use our floor time like I guess
there is a role for those messaging
bills that just lay out what our
principles are but like there's a part
of me that where there's like a little
disingenuousness to it right where all
my colleagues are putting out press
releases and social media statements you
know we did it you know we abolished the
87 000 IRS agents it's like man no you
didn't like be straight with your
constituents that yeah we are in divided
government and the way to be successful
in divided government is you have to lay
out a vision with one hand but you have
to use specific leverage points and so
what I've encouraged Republicans to do
is develop a battle plan right on the
debt limit what is it that we are
demanding in that fight on the National
Defense authorization Act is it the
reinstatement of our military is it
zeroing out the Ukraine funding what is
it that we're fighting for there on the
farm bill what is it that we're that is
most critical there is it food stamp
reform you know and so oftentimes we get
into this legislation and everybody's
after their disparate peace
but there's not real really a Clear
Vision of what victory looks like on
those you know must pass bills and
knowing that I think on the front end
would get more buy-in where we had more
of a populist energy to these reforms
fizzy bear is asking has there been any
talk to pass a law that will prevent the
US government from creating a central
bank digital currency or at the very
least require the government to always
have a forum a physical cash that cannot
be traced no
all right what do you got on on the
Crypt where do you guys fall on the
crypto reg stuff I think that we're in
new place so if you get crypto rewards
from a website
um and then they're worth a dollar each
every token but then they drop to 10
cents the government from what I can
tell wants to come in and tax you on
each of those as if they're still worth
a dollar because that's what they were
when you got them which is
unconscionable so I think it should be
either they tax it the current value or
the lowest value it's been in the last
year when they're taxing the value of
your crypto tokens but not just the
taxes even the regulation of the
marketplaces does is does FTX function
as such a game changer that that those
marketplaces don't just become some
offshore Abyss no uh they will always be
offshore there's nothing we can do to
stop we can only hamper our own ability
to create new currency if we start
because of Sam's horrible misuse of of
of funds at FTX like what that guy did
is worse than what Bernie Madoff did
yeah that's not a reason to destroy the
market although this is the thing man
we're talking about inflation when you
create a new cryptocurrency that's
adding to more inflation we're making
more and more money so I can't tell some
days whether I want to see like sambang
been freed in a jail cell or if you just
pardon him and put him in charge of
Social Security because like if we're
going to run a Ponzi scheme like maybe
we should find the guy that's the best
at it I mean he wasn't that good he kept
doing a lot of different stuff and
having a lot of different parties we got
another Super Champion
yeah we got it from K Band really fast
uh that's uh that's the same one yeah it
was the same one uh but yeah Matt uh
what who do you think trumps VP VP pick
should be
Sarah Huckabee Sanders assuming she does
a good job as governor of Arkansas which
I believe she will like look I mean the
reason why yeah I think the reason Trump
won in 2016 is because a whole lot of
women who didn't like him voted for him
because they could not stand telling
their daughters and granddaughters that
Hillary Clinton was the first female
president of the United States
and what I've said to president Trump is
like you have to create a permission
structure where women who do not like
you vote for you again and like you see
the grit of a Sarah Huckabee Sanders you
see the directness the efficacy
um really bold steps her first days as
Governor Banning tick tock on a lot of
the government devices there
she's the kind of person I'd look at
Christy gnome also I think would be uh
would be a pretty stellar pick
okay we got another 50 Super Chat by N7
wolf archive asking I am a Brit I want
to live in the United States but I am
stopped by the vax Mandate is there a
way Congress can stop it we want you to
stay in Britain
we're tired of being overrun my God I
mean you think about the way immigration
has fundamentally changed the country
how is it how is what has happened there
not a
more prescient warning sign to our
country for real I watch all the Lotus
Eaters episodes shout out to the Lotus
Eaters I'm sure you're cool with that
Tim oh yeah big fan Carl Benjamin yeah
good friend yeah and uh I I watch all of
it I mean I've lived all over the world
my whole life and it's it's Unthinkable
to me that you just open your borders
but I mean you know not to look at us or
anything like that but uh it's it's like
a holdover from when we had very low
population in the 1800s it's like yo
bring your tired you're hungry and
you're poor we need a population now
we're like oversaturated population we
don't need more people
we need great people but we don't need
like masses of people
well and I mean it's it's a misnomer to
suggest that America has not increased
unrestricted immigration throughout
times in our history when it has suited
us and whenever we have had Mass waves
of immigration it has come with times of
strife and conflict
and we invite that now without a real
appreciation for the consequence
search can you go in the beginning
because there's a lot of super chats in
the beginning and I'm only seeing the
latest ones you're able to see is the
Super Chat like the podcast version of
like when people pay the uh Dueling
Pianos guy to like play a certain song
yeah yeah I got one here from Ben Avalon
uh says he's compromising compromising
my rule of never posting on YouTube for
this Super Chat small Tech business
owner in Pensacola here didn't vote for
gates in recent midterm always vote
third party as middle finger to the
system as a matter of principle consider
my mind changed sir well done sir oh I
appreciate that very much ben Avalon I
will be your middle finger Ben
the appendage I assure you a vote for me
will still send a middle finger to
plenty we gotta I promise to you we got
a 10 super chat by man 13 asking how
about a time on the floor to read bills
longer than 50 pages no one can leave
until it's been read through yeah it's a
good one oh that Massey does that
sometimes so it's usually by unanimous
consent that the bill is not read aloud
and so Massey has gone down in times of
frustration and required the reading of
the bills which really only punishes the
clerk right because members aren't there
how about a requirement that folks
actually show up for debate because in
the state legislature your ass had to be
in the seat and you had to be there
because we took votes when the debates
occurred and so you got the benefit of
hearing the different sides of an
argument the way it works in Congress is
all day like you know two three five
people go debate the issues on the floor
and then at night we come in and take a
series of votes on all those matters and
there's no real requirement that people
even appreciate the subtleties and
nuances of the policy choices Marjorie
was telling us that
typically on votes people aren't even
there at all and it's like five people
here and five people there and they just
go like nah and let's pass and they bang
the gavel yeah which was really the
mistake Pelosi made in taking Marjorie
off committees because then Marjorie was
the warden of the floor she would go
down to the floor and demand votes and
call the question and I thought that was
a pretty good thing for the process if
uh if Pelosi were in charge again she'd
probably put Marjorie on all the
Committees yeah we got a question from
Ben d uh says Mr Gates you said Congress
shouldn't trade individual stocks does
this also include the options Futures FX
uh and or any other type of security
yeah because we can impact the value
right of those things right
and we know when the value is changing
based on the briefings we get that the
rest of the American people don't get
right totally A1 has a 20 Super Chat
asking you uh Matt Gates does the USA
need a third political party what are
your thoughts
I don't know I mean what the the first
two we have are so bad
the third one
um
I think we need capture of our existing
Parties by people who
are at least like ideologically informed
because right now
there are times when it feels like it
doesn't even matter which party wins the
election because all you're really
deciding is who gets to be the lead
valet for the same special interests
like it's gut-wrenching to see like oh
well we won we've been promising the
American people for four elections that
we're going to repeal Obamacare and then
Paul Ryan goes and takes 14 million
dollars from hmos in the nine weeks
preceding the role out of our health
care bill and guess what it doesn't
repeal Obamacare it just repositions it
in a way that protects the profits and
the guaranteed Revenue stream for health
insurance companies and and health
management companies and so you know
I've seen the power change but the
bosses never really do did Paul Ryan
pocket that money or any of that money
oh it all went to his political fund but
you know the the pressures on the
presiding officers for fundraising are
intense you know they got a raise like a
million bucks a day you know when we are
in legislative session and Paul Ryan
told me yeah you know I have to go to
three dinners every night and every
dinner has to do about 300 000 bucks
what are they raising money for what's
the point campaigns but what just to
spend money on people door knocking well
in advertising I mean and what I sort of
figured out is well I mean you can do
they're these people who [ __ ]
themselves out for donations from
lobbyists and special interests and then
they use that money to go by 30 seconds
on new the news programs and so instead
of doing all that why not just go beyond
the news programs
yeah you know start a YouTube channel
exactly well yeah yeah do you have a
YouTube channel uh I don't I do actually
I do uh at repackates yeah
I feel like they've got a podcast called
Firebrand oh that connection's 57th
favorite political podcast that's great
but this could actually be a solution to
a certain degree of getting money out of
politics yes
you can you can promote yourself right
and why not just do the thing that you
would otherwise spend the money on and
maybe if we didn't take such crappy
positions and put the lobbyist in charge
of the agenda it wouldn't take 10
million dollars to go win an election
right yeah Jay Lincoln has a 20 Super
Chat asking what do you think about
Texas Pelosi walking back the terrorist
claim
oh man
that that is quite the moniker I am glad
that Congressman Crenshaw clarified that
he was using hyperbole when
using the terrorism label I Know Dan
Crenshaw doesn't think I'm a terrorist I
know they were frustrated with the
tactics we used they were Hardball
tactics sometimes that's what the job
requires Bonnie swedlik asks what are
your thoughts on toxic
no we are one country I am not for this
like secession hell yeah stuff I mean I
love this country and I uh I don't I
don't buy into any of that world view
what about a new state in Northern
California Idaho the state of Jefferson
I haven't spent as much time up there
the the so these are areas like Eastern
Oregon Idaho Northern California which
tend to be more conservative and they
want to be their own State separate from
the dense liberal areas because it's a
very different group of people you know
did you see how many of the recent
counties just voted to actually vote on
it and actually try to join yeah not to
join Jefferson but to join Idaho like
the greater Idaho movement it's like a
lot of Eastern Oregon I didn't know I
just Idaho was so hot right now oh dude
yeah it really is it really is people
are trying to move there too man but as
a Florida man I live in the best state
in the country so I I'm unfamiliar with
these gripes ditto same I'm a floor as
well I'm going back there in a few days
uh we got another great Super Chat by
Brandon hurt and he's asking what is the
when there's a hot issue in Congress
what is the best way to communicate with
my representative email voicemail what
is it it's different for different
members and you need to know what that
leverage point is or influential point
is of four members I mean I get on
Twitter spaces at night I'm real active
at responding to comments on social
media but you know for some of my
colleagues who are septuagenarians and
octogenarians like they get handwritten
reports every day about who called the
landline and so you know you it's
important to get some intelligence part
of political tradecraft is knowing what
influences people and what frustrates me
is like when what influences them is
well you know Facebook hired Chuck
Schumer's daughter do you think you're
going to have like an honest
conversation with Chuck Schumer about
regulating meta right
I got one from Patrick uh he asked Matt
I'm very curious to hear your thoughts
on the current state of the military and
the impact of woke ideologies and
service academies in particular what are
your thoughts no this is this is
something not a lot of people are
talking about but yeah the
uh dimunition and interest in even
serving in the military and especially
the service academies it's palpable yeah
when I first got this job
the coolest part of it was nominating
young people to our service academies
because you get to see the best of your
district and so I had every
valedictorian salutatorian Club
president captain of the football team
applying for these spots and now the
average test scores are lower the
average leadership positions are far
fewer the average GPA class rank down
because the best of the best no longer
want to go to West Point the Naval
Academy the Air Force Academy there are
a few who do but the the gestation
period for that consequence is is pretty
long right and we're going to be feeling
the effects of this in decades because
we weren't getting patriotic God-fearing
Americans into those positions and you
know representing the district I do it's
heartbreaking to hear that I've got
units that are having less live fire
training less or fewer jumps
capabilities reduced and they're
spending all their time in Dei you know
sessions and yeah learning about what
pronouns are acceptable and not
acceptable in the reserves there are
people reporting to me that you can't
say mother and father you just have to
say parent because that's just you know
too binary
they're also walking around in heels in
some instances but that's another story
uh we got a 20 Super Chat by Smashing
random Keys asking does the GOP plan on
training ballot Harvesters if not I fear
the GOP won't win a majority for a while
in some states in California there's
more organized effort there in uh states
that allow it Florida does not allow
ballot harvesting so I don't think we
should do things that are illegal and by
the way everyone acts like this election
Integrity problem is like unsolvable
like how will we ever you know resolve
this and Florida used to be the laughing
stock of the country we had the hanging
Chads and the dimpled Chads and the
pimpled Chads during the 2000 election
and then we got our [ __ ] together and we
had chain of custody requirements for
the ballots and we had transparency over
how many people had voted in real time
every eight minutes every supervisor of
election in Florida has to publish how
many people have voted who those people
are what their party affiliation is and
then when you get to the end there's not
like an opportunity for 150 000 ballots
to be willed into existence or ten
thousand ballots because you know along
the way and if they screw it up and
aren't complying with those transparency
laws you get instant access to an
injunction in a courtroom where those
offices can be put in a state of
receivership by the secretary of state
so we're not going to get screwed over
in Florida by this stuff and if other
states would model our laws they would
be more protected now there are some who
say well we need National laws on these
things and I that that is perilous you
know you start nationalizing elections
it's not going to go the way you think
it might go when
Schumer and Biden and the like get their
say and how states are doing
electioneering what do you think about
federally legislating that compan
companies using proprietary voting
machines where the code is secret so you
don't know what the programs are doing
behind closed doors that we mandate that
they use open source code I mean the the
best open source code is a paper ballot
I mean that's what we've done in Florida
like we don't need your source code if
we can go and look at the paper ballots
and compare them and do Precinct level
audits because you'll you'll get the
canary in the coal mine I feel like with
hundreds of thousands of pieces of paper
that stuff just gets easily lost in the
shuffle literally
not if you have the right chain of
custody requirements have you considered
doing like a blockchain backup on top of
everything there is a lot of talk about
the use of blockchain for that very
reason if you do it use a bunch of
different blockchains like a bunch of
them because one can get hijacked so
like all of them will verify yeah no
that that is the next level of election
Integrity you guys want to try and find
one more real good one yeah I got one
more uh from Rob Hess the Rob has uh
himself uh Gates should have ilhan Omar
get together and put something forward
to repeal the Patriot Act how do you
feel about that I would do it ilhan I'm
ready when you are oh great right on all
right everybody I can barely talk but
this has been absolute blast uh Matt
you're currently my favorite member of
Congress after what went down with the
speaker vote because you know we we had
been talking about this for months for
for the year before the midterms that
even if the Republicans win we don't
think we're going to see any real change
and despite the fact that McCarthy is
still speaker I think you did a lot of
good so I got nowhere to go but down now
now that I'm I've got nothing to do but
disappoint you Tim I hope I don't well
you know no I think it'll be all right
it is what it is but uh smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast I am taking this
weekend to rest my voice obviously but
uh we will be in DC tomorrow at Freedom
Plaza I just probably won't be talking
Matt do you want to shout anything out
uh give me a follow at rep Matt Gates
and check out my podcast Firebrand would
love to love to have some
cross-pollination of this terrific
audience where's Firebrand where can
people find it uh anywhere you can
listen to podcasts we're pretty much
every everywhere our most of our
audience is Apple and was that your
Twitter account and what was it again at
rep Matt Gates is my Twitter account
just went over 2 million Matt nice thank
you so much for for coming here and
answering our questions thank you so
much for uh being here for for two hours
where am I middle of nowhere by the way
it was super weird that you made me put
the blindfold on on the way here
you know everyone does that it's just
this couple seasons was that a goat next
to me probably all right but a lot of
pre people appreciated it especially in
the comment section and thank you so
much for doing it um I just started a
new Rumble channel it's on rumble.com
forward slash we are change I just
posted one of my videos there from my
members area Lucan sensor.com where you
get to have a sneak peek at what uh the
kind of videos I do there almost every
single day rumble.com forward slash we
are change for the spicy videos that you
guys could watch right now thanks for
having me thanks for coming man um more
of these this is fantastic more more
Congress people coming to shows like
this speaking the word of the American
people from the voice of the
representative I'm bringing back
I know you guys are such good friends
but we should hear you and Jim go on
Tech talk about tech and how we got to
deal with big Tech that's really
fascinating I'll make the pitch hell
yeah or ilhan maybe we'll bring ilhan
and talk more power sure absolutely
absolutely I mean Crossing find me
anywhere on the internet search talk me
out I am at serve.com also find me
anywhere on the internet uh I appreciate
your time this is really really cool I
also appreciate you nomining Donald
Trump before I just love hearing the
groan it was just so hilarious and a
little discussion in the den it was just
like oh you can't make that happen the
president vote was my favorite yeah all
right everybody become a member at
timcast.com if you want to support our
work and get access to our uncensored
members only segments thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all tomorrow in
DC at Freedom Plaza 10 a.m 10 A.M 10.